- Rolling.
- [Narrator] How powerful is a kiss?
Can it heal something that's broken
or break something that's healed?
Four ex-couples agreed to kiss on camera.
This is their story.
- Franca, this girl I met after a show.
We dated for like seven months.
- It was going well and then
I went back home to Germany.
- When she came back, it just kinda like,
kinda just lost touch a little bit.
- I don't even know
what I want out of this.
- I still kinda like her.
- Maggie's my high school sweetheart.
- Our families have been
friends for a really long time
and we were friends all
throughout high school,
we just started dating
end of my senior year.
- And then she went off to college,
which stopped our relationship.
- We started this affair
around Valentine's Day.
It was over a month
later because I was still
involved with someone else.
- We both know where we
stand with each other.
- I have a hard time getting
out of relationships.
- Alex is a very unique
person, I would say.
- Dom is a little uptight.
- The big thing was is that
she's kind of chronically
basically late to everything.
- He's also the type of person
that was like very into coasters.
We've had sex on this table,
why can't a cup be on this table?
- Hola.
- Hey.
- What's up?
- Nada.
- Cool.
- Hello.
(laughs)
- Ugh.
- Hi.
(gentle music)
(laughs)
- Okay.
- Good work.
(laughs)
- Oh my god.
- That was hot.
- Kiss was amazing, it was great.
- Shut up.
- Phenomenal.
- I didn't feel that feel.
- Yeah, I'm just not.
- We haven't talked in awhile but like,
if you wanna hang out sometime.
(laughs)
- The kiss
doesn't change anything.
- It's still normal.
- Yeah, no, like for this
moment, super strange,
like once I leave, totally normal.
- It's gonna be fine.
- No that was just wildly personal.
- Yep.
- Yeah.
- Well that's what a kiss is.
- You know the voice in
your head that's like,
oh I should get back with
my ex, I really miss her,
that voice is a lie.
- I think we're on the same page.
- Same chapter.
- Same book.
- She's a slow reader.
- I'm just a slow reader.
(laughs)
- Yeah there we go.
- There's a good old place
where we can kiss again,
deli food and a bench, make out with a
pepperjack turkey in my mouth,
whatever you want, it's just like.
- You're not set on the turkey?
- No no no.
- You're flexible.
- Yeah.
- Cool.
- Jinx.
- I think everyone should stay friends
'cause we're really good friends
and we have an awesome relationship now
so if you can stay friends, do it.
- I'll call you sometime?
- No you won't.
- I know.
(laughs)
- Nope.
- After you, I guess.